bonsoir gérard larcher
prenez le micro bonsoir bienvenue merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bienvenue sur le plateau de public sénat
boon et tous les ans au salon je viens
tous les ans et c'est finalement un
grand plaisir de se retrouver après deux
ans puisqu'il n'y avait pas eu ce lot et
je suis heureux que public sénat soit
présent parce que quelque part ce sont
les territoires
c'est l'agriculture et les entreprises
et être tout près de la coopération
agricole c'est toute la symbol en tous
les cas pour le président du sénat oui
on vient d'entendre des témoignages
d'agriculteurs qui sont inquiets
notamment avec la guerre en ukraine
inquiet sur des hausses éventuelles de 2
des prix des matières dont ils ont
besoin pour travailler tous tout
simplement on attend l'annoncé d'un plan
de résilience par le gouvernement qu'est
ce que vous en attendez vous ils ont
parlé du quoi qu'il en coûte il faut le
il faut le réadapter au monde agricole
et c'est urgent d'abord peut-être
qu'il faut réaffirmer une chose
l'agriculture est le secteur
agroalimentaire c'est le deuxième poste
d'exportation de notre pays après
l'aéronautique et pourtant on a perdu
des parts de marché et rappelé que cette
année nous allons avoir
85 milliards de déficit commercial
quand l'italie à 35 milliards
d'excédents je ne parle même pas de
l'allemagne c'est inatteignable pour
nous si je dis ça c'est dire que on
n'est pas simplement
dans la nostalgie dans la rencontre d'un
mode de vie on est aujourd'hui devant
une activité économique qui emploient
des hommes et des femmes qui j'allais
dire occupe au sens le plus positif le
territoire qui porte des valeurs que
représente la ruralité et qui en même
temps pour notre balance des paiements
est tout à fait essentiel je rappelle
plus près de 14 milliards d'euros alors
ils sont inquiets est ce que vous dites
comme marine le pen par donc on a
entendu tout à l'heure que le quoi qu'il
en coûte ne les a pas concernés si
d'abord eu
ce qui les a concerné c'est qu'ils ont
fait face bien sûr souvenez-vous du
confinement souvenez-vous de ce qui se
passait quand les commerces étaient
fermés ou extrêmement limitées nous
avons vu que les agriculteurs avec ce
qui conduisait les camions ce qui était
les caissières dans les supermarchés
comme les soignants ils ont été en
première ligne ne l'oublions pas ils ont
répondu et ils ont répondu présent parce
que ce sont des hommes et les femmes qui
connaissent le quotidien et qui s'engage
je crois que
n'oublions pas de leur rendre hommage
même près de deux ans après matthew vous
rappeliez tout à l'heure la place
centrale qu'occupe l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire dans l'économie
française voyant que ça occupe c'est
vrai beaucoup beaucoup de personnes mais
il ya beaucoup de ces personnes qui
n'arrivent pas en vivre qui sont dans
une situation de détresse pas face au
très faible niveau de rémunération est
surtout très faible partage de la valeur
dans toute la chaîne de production
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que ça fait
des années que les politiques en parlent
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
voilà pourquoi nous avons débattu deux
fois d'un texte qu'on a appelés et gally
main et galim 2 pour tenter que le
producteur ne soit pas la variable
d'ajustement
dernier de la chaîne une fois que la
distribution et la transformation
s'étaient mis d'accord je crois que nous
progressons mais qu'il va falloir être
extrêmement attentif voilà pourquoi au
sénat
j'étais accompagné de notamment de la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques et de sénateurs de la
commission des affaires économiques
parce qu'il va falloir voir si
l'objectif que s'est donné le texte
égalise 2 et bien atteint pour que tout
simplement les producteurs les
agriculteurs puis vivre d'un revenu
décent et que ce revenu décent quelque
part il est le fruit de leur travail et
de leur contribution à cette balance
commerciale que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure alors gérard larcher on va
parler maintenant de
de cette guerre en ukraine hier au sénat
il ya eu un débat organisé juste
apprécié de l'assemblée sur la guerre en
ukraine le premie nice qui a défendu
ardemment l'action des manuels macro est
ce qui vous a convaincu goûter nous
sommes dans un moment d'union nationale
et d'union de l'europe en fait la crise
en ukraine me semble avoir révélé trois
choses première chose révélé un peuple
les ukrainiennes et les ukrainiens
dont on n'avait sans doute pas mesuré le
désir qu'ils avaient de vivre en
démocratie et avec nos valeurs et
peut-être que la dîmière poutine
lui-même l'avait estimé d'ailleurs sans
doute et l'a révélé une europe qui était
capable de se retrouver et notamment
mieux qu'en 2014 au moment de l'invasion
de la crimée et bien une europe qui est
capable de prendre un certain nombre de
mesures et y compris des pays qu'on
attendait -
l'allemagne sa réaction qui n'était pas
facile sur la question de l'énergie et
puis son réarmement qui est une espèce
de mutations extrêmement importante car
depuis 1945 et lé drame de la deuxième
guerre mondiale l'allemagne
s'interdisait toute
exportation
d'armes létales dans des pays un conflit
et ce a décidé e sa décision aussi de
redonner à son armée les moyens d'être
une armée à la hauteur de l'allemagne et
de l'union européenne révélation de
l'europe capable d'imposer des sanctions
des sanctions financières des sanctions
personnelles des sanctions à caractère
de mobilité et puis la troisième des
choses
elle a montré que le tan était capable
aussi de se réveiller que ce qu'on nous
avait annoncé comme un état de mort
cérébrale était finalement j'allais dire
bien vivante et c'est l'e3 effet lorsque
j'ai ressenti je n'ai pas répondu
travail ou sur ce sujet thaler on désire
caisse consentis les agriculteurs au
fond on va avoir une tension sur les
prix de l'énergie il le mesure on va
voir une tension sur le marché mondial
parce que 30 % du marché mondial est
actuellement bloquée dans les ports de
la mer noire je ne vois pas de détroit
des dardanelles serait ouvrir rapidement
avec des conséquences très important à
la fois sur les prix mais ne soyons pas
égoïstes les premières conséquences ils
vont se jouer d'ici quelques semaines
dans la fourniture de céréales
dont on dit d'après les fiches qu'un
président du sénat reçoit que d'ici
quelques semaines la situation de
tension serait très forte en algérie au
maroc en egypte au liban et donc il ya
une responsabilité géopolitique qui est
lié à cette crise mais qu'est ce qu'on
va faire ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que le blé français on va en avoir
besoin nous ici on va pas on va pas le
proposer à ces pays nous ne pourrons pas
de laisser ces pays oui j'allais dire
j'en sors
de l'union européenne c'est l'europe qui
doit viser une région dit
pardonnez moi on va pas abandonner cette
partie du monde non plus les rendre
otage puis la troisième des choses ce
matin j'ai ressenti c'est on va avoir
des phénomènes de tension est réelle
pour les agriculteurs par exemple sur
les engrais plus de 40% des engrais
venait de biélorussie de russie ou
d'ukraine nous ils vont avoir des
tensions sur les semences qui venait de
chez nous et notamment de notre pays or
l'ensemencement de printemps c'est en ce
moment et vous voyez bien que la
conséquence sur les récoltes de
l'automne puis de l'année prochaine on
est extrêmement importante voilà
pourquoi la seule réponse elle peut elle
doit être elle ne peut être
qu'européenne voir il faut prendre des
décisions ensemble qui merci rapidement
je reprends la main parce que le prix
dans la république parle aux français ce
soit à 20 heures on peut dire c'est
normal la france l'europe durcissent le
ton et les sanctions contre la russie
est ce que vous voyez dans cette prise
de parole une forme de distorsion de
concurrence à moins de 40 jours du
premier tour de la présidentielle si le
président nous parle ce soir des sujets
qui sont ni à l'ukraine la réponse
européenne
qu'ils informent les françaises et les
français en sa responsabilité de chef de
l'état ça m'apparaît normal et naturel
mais nous sommes à trente neuf jours oui
nous sommes à 35 jours d'un moment qu
est
dans la vème république
on sa démocratie
l'élection présidentielle est ce moment
clé ne peut pas être
escamotée voilà pourquoi j'ai appelé le
président de la république bien sûr à
exercer pleinement ses missions de chef
de l'état deux présidents l'union
européenne en exercice moi-même dans
deux semaines je présiderai
avec les présidents des commissions des
affaires économiques de tous les
parlements nationaux
de l'union européenne la conférence sur
les souverainetés on voit bien que la
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
va se poser de manière fort gyger a
lancé mais en même temps il faut une
réponse une réponse et un débat
démocratique
car on ne peut pas élire un président ou
une présidente sans un débat sur le
bilan sur le projet on ne peut pas élire
un président ou une présidente en
quelque sorte par défaut démocratiques
réclamés par exemple un débat télévisé
avant le premier tour en tous les cas je
demande vraiment au président de la
république de bien réfléchir de la
manière dont il va être candidat parce
que si nous escamote on se débat
pour celui ou celle qui sera élu il y
aura un problème de légitimité et nous
sommes dans une démocratie fragile on
l'a vu avec la crise des gilet jaune
nous avons besoin que celui ou celle qui
va avoir le pays en responsabilité est
vraiment illégitimité enracinée et en
démocratie je ne connais pas autre chose
que le débat donc ça veut dire vous
pronostiquez sa victoire je ne
pronostique pas j'ai dit celui ou celle
je mène au stick un vrai débat entre
celui ou celle je reprends la question
que je soutiens s'appelle valérie
pécresse si vous voulez les précisions
on en était au courant mai
vous ne le prenez pas mais c'est vrai
que sa compagne est difficile pas
seulement la sienne celle de tous de
tous les candidats reçus ont existé dans
une campagne assez varié qui est sous
cloche d'une salle la campagne n'est pas
simple mais nous pouvons à la fois gérer
de manière rassembler de manière unie
la crise créée par l'agression de la
russie contre l'ukraine et l'agression
il faut lui dire contre les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres et en même temps faire
vivre la démocratie et moi j'appelle à
la fois l'unité et en même temps faire
vivre la démocratie
oui mais quand finalement un ancien
premier ministre jean pierre raffarin
saisit alors je vais pas dire le
prétexte mais argumente son ralliement
emmanuel macron par cette crise
internationale bon ça fragilise encore
plus votre candidate ça s'éteint c'est
un constat auquel vous pouvez pas
échapper écoutez opérateurs un fait de
choix qui est le sien moi je considère
que je peux être j'allais dire dans
l'unité nécessaire du pays comme
président du sénat mais aussi ma
responsabilité d'appeler à ce débat
démocratique et puis après les
françaises et les français choisiront
celle ou celui qui au deuxième tour
s'affronteront et français choisiront
mais une démocratie c'est un choix ça
n'est pas un non-choix pain et pas nos
choix peut nous conduire demain à une
crise politique forte une dernière
question valérie pécresse a accepté de
débattre le 10 mars prochain face à eric
zemmour sur sur tf1 on a un peu le
sentiment que ce sera le débat de de la
dernière chance pour stopper sa chute
dans les dans les sondages on avait déjà
dit ça avant son premier grand meeting
ça s'est pas très bien passé comment
vous abordez un rendez vous comme celui
là j'aborde ce rendez vous avec les
qualités personnelles de valérie
pécresse mais aussi avec son
positionnement
extrêmement claires autour et des
valeurs
quant à eric zemmour chacun sait qu'il a
considéré jusqu'à une date récente que
poutine et l agressé et que
ukraine et l agresseur il me semble que
tout est dit et que les françaises et
les français
qui ont besoin de se retrouver autour
des valeurs feront un choix extrêmement
clair merci